thank you Matt well done now we want you
to get as much as possible out of this
year's showcase so this year after we're
done here in the hangar we're just going
to keep the showcase going now for those
of you watching at home our pre show
hosts Adam Sessler and Morgan Webb will
be back to take over the stream and
they'll bring you exclusive interviews
and more information about all the games
that we're talking about here tonight
here in Los Angeles we've built an
interactive space over on the other side
of the lot we have a chance to learn
more about our games play some of them
and meet some of our developers over
there there is also food drink and to
make sure it's a real party we have a
range of special performance by
blink-182 who will drop their new album
will drop their new album california in
a couple of weeks and you get to hear
them live tonight as they start their
summer tour now we have another treat
for you over there as well a chance to
experience the latest in virtual reality
from Bethesda weren't expecting that
were you
now the first time anyone exponent
experienced modern VR was at e3 2012 and
if you were there and lucky enough you
may remember getting to play doom 3 bfg
in our booth now at the time we had
solved some of the toughest technology
challenges posed by VR and people were
amazed since then we've quietly
continued our pioneering work in VR and
tonight we want you to see and
experience what you feel when you put on
a headset and play the latest Triple A
games in the industry and we have two
games for you to experience the first is
the just release doom you can take a
virtual tour of hell and get a totally
unique look at the very latest and
graphics and true next-gen rendering
from our EdTech six engine in addition
we think the greatest promise of VR is
its ability to immerse players
completely into virtual worlds and that
the best games for that experience will
be first person open-world RPGs so we
have fallout 4 for you to play as well
wander the wasteland check out the
iconic red rocket tricom back I'm
telling you with a pip-boy on your arm a
dog by your side a gun in your hand it's
pretty incredible tonight we're pleased
to announce that fallout 4 will be
released in 2017 on the HTC vive
platform
and if you thought survival mode was an
intense way to experience fallout you
ain't seen nothing yet we want to give
you a glimpse into where we're headed
with VR where you can expect us to
remain a leader offering our games on
the very best platforms you choose so be
sure to check it out now for more on the
second half of the showcase let's check
in with Adam and Morgan to see what's
happening and get an update on what they
have planned Adam Morgan what do you
have for us thanks Pete now we are here
at B iii+ and this is sort of this
experience that you guys are going to
get to see after the show case we have
some Bethesda VR over here now right now
there's no line so that's kind of
tempting is it taking advantage of that
and over here Elder Scrolls legends for
everyone to play Pete I fully expect to
see you at one of these tables showing
off that card masteries skill I know you
possess now in here we're actually Adam
and I are actually gonna be interviewing
some of the developers that you guys
just saw their games on stage so we're
gonna have a lot more information for
you so everybody on the stream needs to
stay tuned for that after lots of good
info but for the moment let's go back to
Pete and even more games Thank You Adam
Morgan we will see you guys in a few
minutes but we are not going